thank you
[Music]
it all began
July 11th oh
strange beings the local said visiting
an isolated indigenous communicate a
community in rural Peru at night
harassing its inhabitants and attempting
to kidnap a 15 year old girl holy crap
sound of Freedom too
[Laughter]
space intergalactic
these gentlemen are aliens they seem
armored like the Green Goblin from
Spider-Man I have shot one twice and it
didn't fall instead it elevated and
disappeared says the local leader of the
indigenous ekitu group living in the
Northwestern maintenance Province while
on Apple Peruvian radio station while on
acid
no I'm just kidding dude quote we're
frightened by what is happening in the
community okay this is going on recently
improved in an indigenous area where
[__] space beings are coming down and
harassing yeah but what they think a
helicopter is a space vehicle they're
indeed no because they're also familiar
with what the Green Goblin is from
Spider-Man so they they know they know
that Toby Maguire
no it looks like uh that's their frame
of reference that's tight that's nice
that's cool that's cool
Green Goblin
all right the funny [__] is like when
people think like indigenous they think
like uncontacted tribe right but then
like when I was with this monk tribe in
Thailand there they live in huts and
then you look inside they got a TV and
VCR all that [__] hooked up dude yeah
they got [__] they got you but they are
Sega indigenous
quote their color is silver their shoes
are round in shape and with those they
rise up they float one meter high and
have a red light on their heel instead
of villa sounds like a [__] LA Gear
light up
long their mask is long and their eyes
are sort of yellowish okay let me show
you some photos Okay
Jabberwocky dude what what is this what
are you looking at I don't even see the
photo this is a photo of one of these
beings that is coming down and harassing
this indigenous driving zoom in are we
looking at the front or the back I want
to see nothing other than a lens flare
look
this is in the sky oh oh they're kind of
like ghost they're kind of ghoulie dude
they're ghosty he shot that thing why
does it have to be so unclear it's
always unclear that's a prerequisite for
a alien shot so what do you shoot him
with he's not an alien yeah
says in this in this they have Twitter I
enhance one of the videos the one where
they shine a flashlight on one of the
alleged creatures and say there it is I
don't know what we're seeing here is it
a being or just tree branches hashtag
UFO Twitter all right news of the
alleged extraterrestrial attackers
quickly spread online as believer
Skeptics and internet sleuths around the
world analyze grainy videos posted by
members of the ikitu community they're
all on Twitter stop talking about
internet sluice bro I'm sick of the
reported sightings okay I'll stop
talking about internet suits Nick is
sick of it
came on the heels of U.S Congressional
hearings about unidentified aerial
phenomenon that ignited a global
conversation about the possibility of
E.T life visiting Earth that's cool now
again these people are [__] coming in
the late hours and harassing the
community and potentially kidnapping 15
year old girls and stuff like that all
right what only girls a kid oh who will
happen to be a female one
what hey is she they attempted or they
did they attempted oh they're pedal
aliens
dang that's crazy sound of Freedom alien
version Independence Day Intergalactic
sound or is it just a bunch of dudes
dressed up as aliens trying to you know
trick him into thinking like because
that's their disguise it's like wait
let's trick this indigenous tribe into
thinking it's aliens Guardians of the
Galaxy I don't know they have freaking
what are those you know those jet packs
you could wear to like float above damn
dude super loud
[Laughter]
and it starts now
I don't know man I feel this sounds
hella like I'm hating but like I feel
even less
like it's less believable if it's like a
tribe that probably has religious
beliefs that are already kind of
different
for them to say they saw an alien
you know what I think they saw a [__]
animal you know what I think Ryan just
doesn't believe in aliens I think Peru
is sacred grounds dog I think I think
that's where they're trying to bring
tourists to come spend in their Village
what are they selling like alien jerky
they're trying
alien Journey too much alien Jurgen I
can't even offload this like you guys
good marketing
good story yeah yeah you gotta buy the
jerky and save all the young females in
our village or whatever
that's the GoFundMe that's a fundraiser
it would be really messed up if they
were being harassed by just some dude in
a costume
members of the Peruvian Navy and police
travel to the isolated Community which
is located 10 hours by boat from the
mainas provincial capital of Iquitos to
investigate the strange disturbances in
early August and it's happening every
night it's just happening every now and
then last week authorities announced
that they believed the perpetrators were
members of illegal gold mining gangs
from Colombia and Brazil
interesting Advanced flying technology
to terrorize the community
to get them to leave huh so the jet
packs not the water ones yeah yeah but
the regular Iron Man style jet packs do
you think they were using the boat and
then they they get they got fishing
string and then they put like a little
like a like a yeah like bed sheet or
something and then they made it with the
cut out eyes yeah yeah but it's like a
modern version to grab the person and
yeah to reel it out actually how that
feels to be like an indigenous tribe and
then to see a technological thing that
nothing like that that's true that must
feel crazy it's gonna be ridiculous
right because they gotta make it more
believable than that because if it's
just a hovering thing with like whatever
it just it flies away but imagine the
guy who came up with the idea about that
right just being like all right these
[__] have never seen this [__]
before and it's like we're gonna go get
jet packs and pretend we're aliens so
then what's that for us
[Laughter]
actually the reverse yeah it's like
something primitive we go that's gotta
be a [__] alien yeah
clean your glasses Lou oh sorry yeah so
the lead investigator the lead
investigator on the case said that 80 of
illegal gold dredging in the region is
located in the nanaya River Basin which
is where the ekitsu community that's low
bro that's crazy just to Jack the gold
and one of the key pieces to the
investigation was related to the
attempted kidnapping of a 15 year old
girl this sounds like a Scooby-Doo
episode maybe they only kidnapped that
girl because she was a witness and saw
them and they were like oh damn it we
gotta grab her she's smart grab her I
bet that's what it was he's like you're
not a ghost yeah
you're not a ghost you're just a guy
with a spreadsheet
that's how they sound in Peru
I mean it's not too far off I mean
people do that type of stuff all the
time like cult leaders will make you
think they're a spiritual being just a
[__] you in the ass yeah
so crazier things have been done for
Less Rewards
by the powers of Christ
oh
[Laughter]
yeah girls love that that'll suck my
dick
it's true dude
it's sad man you can
[Laughter]
yeah
sad bro but dude
people do be throwing aliens in the mix
just to get stuff man that sucks aliens
are hot right now bro they're the
hottest things everybody wants to talk
about aliens I do want to talk about
aliens I like if they're real I want to
talk about them yeah but what do you
think they said that it's real the day I
come in here and I tell you guys I saw a
[__] alien you'll know I'm telling
the truth that's true but you're not so
much pranking us though I'm gonna walk
out you like too much yeah Nick look in
there I'll be like what and then I get
slimed or something
because Ryan has access to slime you bro
would that surprise you he is wild you
think I would do that put slime on you I
don't know maybe if the cameras were on
and it was good for engagement and uh
views I think it would yeah I don't want
to talk about aliens at all why not I'm
over it because it's always it's always
like oh controversy this conspiracy well
I'm [__] I'm sorry [__] I don't give a
[__] about aliens yeah can we not talk
about aliens all the time what about
[__] Bigfoot water jet packs yeah
yeah yeah
what about I would like to know why are
they so shy
I don't know they're so [__] they're not
even real I don't think they're real no
because every time they're like real no
dude unless I see one right we are
aliens to other life forms on another
planet surprise you don't [__] with
aliens bro look yeah you do Ayahuasca no
right this is the most open-minded we
fly to Mars yeah if there was a living
anything there they would look at us
like what the [__] like we exist it's
not funny if they saw you looked you
right in the face and went no way yeah
what it looks like glarp
that's alien language can even though
you don't believe it's real bro yeah who
knows man hey you know what sick too is
that when before the [__] world was
Global like before everyone could travel
that [__] must look like alien you see a
Chinese guy that's true dude where are
the aliens still is in some areas of
America and then you taste their food
you're like this [__] [__] hits
imagine you see an Eskimo in real life
you've never seen one before you're like
that's a [__] aliens yeah true dude I
mean you live in an ice house this is
crazy you know yeah it's called the
igloo no ice house it's in the Ice House
foreign